there are no Miracles at this site
nobody being found alive
just Grim work done in shocked silence
every time a piece of wreckage is lifted
it exposes fragments of victims
remnants of lives brought to a sudden
Dreadful end
it's like a huge bomb that suddenly fell
and burned everything in its path
now it's really sad looking at remains
and thinking that a few hours ago this
was a human being full of life
this recovery work will go on for at
least a week as we watched again and
again ambulances took away more bodies
from this perspective you can see
exactly what happened the passenger
train emerged out of that tunnel at
around 100 miles an hour some of the
carriages are still on the track and
then it crashed head first into a
freight train going in the other
direction and some of those Freight
containers are still up there it was a
devastating explosion look at that lump
of brown metal there that used to be a
carriage it's been scorched by
temperatures of around 1 300 degrees
Celsius
the hospital in nearby Larissa is where
the most Gravely injured survivors are
being treated
father nicoforos is here to comfort them
and their families he told us many are
too shocked to speak bewildered by
what's happened to them
why always in a difficult situation like
this we ask why why should this happen
to me just a short while ago I had my
kid in my arms told him goodbye and now
he's lost why
this tragic Vista is also a crime scene
the local station master has been
arrested and charged with manslaughter
but this whole Railway network is
outdated
something went catastrophically wrong
here
and this field littered with the signs
of death
is the result
Adam Parson Sky News Tempe